part of our series every state has a
story we're focusing on issues that are
on the campaign campaign trail and also
affecting real people and their everyday
lives and major Garrett joins me now
you've got an installment in that series
a multi-generational story it really is
you know when we were here four years
ago covering the primary the opioid
conversation was just beginning to
filter into the broader campaign
conversation now Democrats campaigning
here not only talked about it all the
time but they make stops to meet voters
at rehab facilities that explains the
pervasiveness of this crisis and as we
learned it's devastating effect on
families here in New Hampshire
Paula Wilson is 64 years old and a
recovering opioid addict who has also
struggled with alcoholism
she's the cleanest family member to
raise 16 year-old Devon her grandson
he's a high-risk kid because of a number
of factors you know his early childhood
experiences the family history Devon at
times reluctantly has lived with Paula
for eight years I don't really think I'm
gonna pass it on the song I kind of just
ignore it
the toll on the Wilson family almost
unimaginable both my husband's were
heroin addicts three of my children have
been multi drug use but primarily
opioids have been their drug of choice
that's a lot for one family
it is a lot it's a large family and the
cycle of addiction is strong and
repetitive so we're in moved to a young
reporter of a 55 year old female who was
overdose Manchester New Hampshire
District Fire Chief Mike Gamache we see
some of the same people all the time
last week in Manchester firefighters
found this woman unconscious on a
sidewalk before she came to they suspect
she overdosed on opioids the opioid
epidemic of sticking wrong New Hampshire
is among the top five states for opioid
involved deaths its mortality rate is
more than twice the national average
New Hampshire has been particularly
hard-hit Democratic candidates field
questions about opioids and almost every
stop and the time has come to recognize
that addiction is a medical issue when
these pharmaceutical executives know
that they are pushing a drug that hurts
people and they keep pushing it they are
personally responsible they can be held
criminally responsible several have
highlighted the issue at rehab
facilities research shows the number of
children across the country in foster
care due to parental drug use has more
than doubled in the past 20 years
something experts have linked in part to
the opioid epidemic we're raising a
nation of parentless children directly
related to the opioid crisis the biggest
loss is that grandchild relationship
it's it's it's something to grieve over
you've got to be the heavy yeah I am the
heavy you know I am I'm the parent Deven
swims and runs track he likes hanging
with athletes and says he's seen enough
of addiction no fear nothing know about
my future I don't know I'm not scared at
all
Paula told us she started talking to
Devin about the fears that she has that
he will fall into this opioid use
problem when he was about 10 years old
it's part of the stress in their
relationship because her fears are so
pervasive and he's tired of talking
about it he wants to move on and build a
future for himself Tony and it's part of
this generational dilemma in the state
what are candidates saying they're gonna
do to change the dynamic so all the
Democrats are saying look hold the drug
companies accountable pursue them in
civil court or a possible criminal court
Andrew yang @p Buddha judge have said
hey maybe it's okay to have legalization
for small amounts of opioids President
Trump declared this a public health
emergency in 2017 and it suggested the
death penalty for people who sell
opioids illegal major thank you very
much
it's a reminder of the stakes when
elections happen and for anyone out
there who's feeling a little cynical
about politics you've had enough of it I
suggest come out to a polling place like
we have today when you see people walk
by and participate in that simple
American tradition that simple act of
casting a vote it truly is inspiring
guys it's always exciting to see that
happening Tony thanks